Salut si vous tombez sur ma chaine pour la première fois sachez que cette année
le 1er janvier je me suis donné pour
défi de faire une vidéo par jour
pendant un an, pendant 366 jours sur
youtube.
Après avoir fait mes adieux à mes amis
A ma famille, à mon lit aussi parce que je ne l'ai pas trop vu cette année, j'ai allumé ma caméra et
j'ai sauté dans le vide de la création en
essayant de ne pas trop perdre en
qualité et versus la quantité des vidéos que je vais devoir faire
fin janvier nous étions 500 abonnés
sur la chaîne vous étiez 500 à regarder les
vidéos et à me suivre et moi interagir
avec vous peut-être que vous étiez la
dites le moi si  vous en faisiez partie et je
découvrais un game que je connaissais
pas moi je croyais que Youtube
c'était juste une plateforme pour
mettre ses idées en ligne et les
partager sur les réseaux sociaux par
exemple j'aurait pu d'ailleurs choisir
n'importe quel site pour faire ça je
suis pas sûr que ça aurait fait la
même chose sur ma dropbox mais bon
quand je me suis lancé le défi
c'était pour me stimuler dans la
réécriture de mon spectacle qui
maintenant est prêt à partir dans
quelques jours en tournée donc je ne
reverrai toujours pas ma famille
toujours pas mes amis
et toujours pas mon lit et si vous voulez
venir me voir jouer quelque part en
France, il y a un lien dans la description
qui vous emmène sur toutes les dates de
de tournée
au mois de février j'organise une FAQ sur la chaîne et
Olivier Nicoleau me lance une vanne il me mets au défi de me mettre à nu
sur la chaîne si un jour j'ai atteins
les 100 mille abonnés avant le 31
décembre
la belle idée qu'on a là ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est qu'à ce moment là vous êtes un millier
de personnes à me suivre sur la chaîne
c'était déjà énorme et c'était
inenvisageables qu'on soit 100
fois plus d'ici le 31 décembre donc
j'ai dit oui en rigolant
aujourd'hui
je rigole moins
on ne reviendra dans quelques minutes
alors ça ça voudrait dire qu'on aurait
atteint les 100 mille avant la fin de
l'année donc je prends pas trop de risques
il n'y a pas des problème c'est un engagement
Olivier Nicoleau fin mars il y a mon pote
Pierre Croce qui m'invite à faire une vidéo
avec lui sur sa chaîne et là vous
êtes 17000
à me découvrir et à apprécier au point
de venir suivre mes vidéos 17000 mon
gars 17000 c'est l'équivalent de 8 Olympias
En avril il ya la fameuse baffe
de joey starr vous souvenez de ça ça
m'avait donné une idée ce jour-là de
parler de la CNV, la communication
non-violente dans une vidéo je me dis
bon c'est pas très grave ça va pas
intéresser grand monde mais je trouve
ça important de parler de la CNV
un jour et c'est là qu'on voit que
j'ai du flaire puisque c'est la
première vidéo qui passent les
cent mille vu le bon mentaliste hien quand c'est
des choses qui me concerne je me plante
tout le temps c'est aussi à cette même
période que vous avez commencé vous à sous-titrer les vidéos
pour les rendre accessibles aux
malentendants je voulais vous remercier
pour ça c'est souvent le même nom que
soit passée quand je valide les
sous-titres, je les valides à peu près une
fois par semaine et je vois les mêmes noms
merci merci beaucoup bravo ne
lâchez rien continuer c'est un grand
geste d'accessibilité que vous faites
pour les autres pour les huit derniers
mois qui accélère en juin il y a Lola Dubini
Lola Dubiniii qui m'invite sur sa chaine et en plus de se marrer elle me fait découvrir à sa propre
communauté en août je vous fais un mois
complet d'énigmes, 32 énigmes et en
septembre je réalise juste des rêves
je rencontre Bernard Verbert
je fais des feat
avec des mecs comme Romain de Tech News and Tests comme Emmy Make Up pro comme Chris
de la chaîne poisson fécond
et avec le Grand William
Le seul l'unique
pas d'Arcachon non Doc Seven, Doc Seven me fait passer dans une de
ses vidéos dans un "salut internet" et la c'est 19000 personnes qui le jour
même
viennent voir mes vidéos
c'est l'ultime lancé
c'est Doc c'est mon parrain. Peu de
temps après on se retrouve 100000
sûr la chaîne du Mental Vlog, chaîne qui, je le rappel, j'avais fais
juste pour me stimuler dans la
réécriture et comme vous êtes
adorable avec moi vous m'avez bien mis
dans le temps la promesse que j'avais
fais au mois de février la mise à nu
et moi je vous ai dis qu'on y
reviendrai que pour la dernière vidéo
La 366ème
c'est-à-dire celle-ci. Bon j'ai, j'ai
j'ai cherché la faille hein quand même
hein je me suis dit que j'allais emmener ma caméra et que j'allais la tourner à Poil
Y'a une ville qui s'appelle Poil, je me suis dis je vais la tourner là-bas
j'ai cherché sur internet ça a déjà
été fait et puis au final je me suis
dis non je vais pas tourner autour du pot
je vais faire une vraie mise à nu
celle qui révèle tout mais vraiment
tout ou il n'y a rien de caché
qui révele tout tout tout tout tout tout LA mise a nu
Et pour tout réveler
il faut commencer le 22 novembre 1982
je suis né le 22 novembre 1982 à Marcigny
c'est un village à quelques kilomètres
heu qui est au nord de La Rochelle. Assez tôt
quand j'étais très jeune
j'étais jaloux de ma grande soeur qui allait
à la bibliothèque et je réclamais à
ma mère de faire pareil je savais pas
lire mais c'était pas grave voulais
faire comme les grands donc j'allais
là-bas je prenais surtout des bd pour
commencer à la même période on avait
un voisin c'était un vieux monsieur qui
s'appelait Jacques il habitais à côté de
chez nous
et il m'a proposé de m'apprendre un jeu. à chaque fois que je pouvais j'allais le
soir chez lui et il se montrait très
patient
très très gentil pour heu, pour
m'apprendre des choses pour discuter
avec moi il m'a fait naître le goût de
comprendre les choses de savoir comment
les choses fonctionnent bref c'est
devenu mon meilleur copain pour jouer avec
moi jusqu'à cinq ans je connaissais pas
de personne pour jouer aux échecs toute
manière avec moi. Et c'est à 8 ans que je découvre l'univers de la magie et du
mentalisme dans un livre de Robert Véno
qui s'appelle "cours magica" et c'est
aussi à cette période que je commence à
monter des spectacles pour les repas
entre amis que mes parents organisent. Alors
bon ça c'est cool je fais complet à chaque fois
mais je vais surtout complètement
n'importe quoi et c'est pas très
longtemps après que ma mère m'emmène
passer un test de QI dans un village
juste à côté de chez nous qui
s'appelle Lauzière je me souviens vraiment de
ce moment parce que c'est là qu'on a
compris que j'utilisais ma mémoire un
petit peu différemment. Vient ensuite la
période du collège. Alors, j'avais pas
beaucoup d'amis on va pas ce le cacher et
j'étais pas le mec super populaire mais
j'avais accès aux CDI et ça
j'étais content j'avais quand même quelques
potes un peu barré aussi je vous rassure
mais c'est vraiment au lycée après au
lycée Léon Zieul de La Rochelle que
je découvre vraiment la joie des potes
des filles
des soirées des abus et donc du
redoublement et ouais les mecs
j'ai redoublé ma seconde mais au
bénéfice de découvrir que je
savais me faire des amis donc au
final je regrette pas à Vieljeu j'ai eu
aussi heu, des groupes de
musique le plus important de ces groupes là
a été Yataki pour moi, si y'a
des gens qui ont connu Yataki dites le
dans les commentaires on faisait pas mal
de concerts dans la région et même en
dehors c'était vraiment cool et j'ai
pas continué mes études après le lycée
C'est le...
Alors le système scolaire ça a
jamais été trop mon kiff j'ai
préféré me formé dans les livres sur le
terrain dans des formations spécifiques
j'aime vraiment beaucoup apprendre mais
j'aime quand c'est efficace et dense
après j'enchaînais des choses vraiment
très variés à 17 ans j'étais
formateur bafa en Pays de la Loire et sur
le tout le territoire national à 18 ans
je faisais le marché en vendant des
nappes 100% polyester anti-taches
infroissable un coup d'éponge au
quotidien allez-y madame c'est pas cher à
19 ans je fais un passage en
restauration avec mon pote Denis
ont été les seules à La Rochelle
a avoir un restaurant qui faisait du
savoyard et ça s'appelait "la petite
souris" on s'est vraiment bien marrer et
c'etait un bon moyen pour moi d'être en
au contact chaque jour de nouvelles
personnes pour comprendre aussi comment
fonctionnent les relations sociales jusqu'au
jour où j'ai voulu changer c'est un des
point de mon fonctionnement c'est que j'aime
vraiment découvrir
des choses différentes mais au bout
d'un moment si je commence à en faire le
tour je veux changer je repars souvent
de zéro dans des nouvelles aventures
j'ai ensuite en vrac ouvert une
société d'animation à domicile je
faisais aussi de la magie et du mentalisme pour des événements privés
ce qu'on appelle de l'événementiel et
petit à petit j'ai commencé à
travailler à l'étranger j'ai beaucoup
travaillé à l'étranger entre mentaliste
alors soit sur scène soit sur des fomations sur le nom verbal sur la
mémoire aussi et sur tous les sujets
sur lesquels je m'étais passionné
depuis presque l'enfance bref une
trentaine de pays par an et c'est en
même temps que j'ai découvert le
plaisir de faire des spectacles d'humour
grâce à un pote qui s'appelle michel
coubard et qui m'a emmené sur scène
sur le festival du rire de saint-martin
détaille-t-il
ii michel si tu regarde cette vidéo je
veux que je te dédie cette vidéo parce
que t'es aussi un peu mon, mon parrain aussi
et en 2011 je pose mes valises à
Paris et comme je suis à Paris je me
dis tiens je vais peut-être essayer de m'ocuper en faisant du théâtre
et je commence à jouer dans un théâtre qui s'appelle la comédie des trois bornes c'est
un spectacle j'avais écrit qui
s'appelait maux de tête
et j'y mélangeais vraiment humour magie et mentalisme en pensant que le mentalisme
n'allait pas trop intéresser les gens et
je me suis complètement planté comme
quoi ce n'était pas une bonne prédiction de
mentaliste plus que très rapidement j'ai
supprimé la magie pour ne laisser que
le mentalisme m'entourer de personnes
pour m'aider et
le spectacle devient "Fabien Olicard vous mentalise" que j'ai joué jusqu'à cette année
il s'est passé des trucs de ouf depuis 2011 jusqu'à aujourd'hui
J'ai joué au Point Virgule
au grand Point Virgule j'ai joué au
Québec j'ai joué à l'Olympia sur le
plateau du point virgule j'ai joué
partout en france j'ai fais des rencontres
de ouf j'ai vu l'envolée de mon
pote Jeff Panacloc depuis les cabarets
jusqu'au zénith où j'ai fait ses
premières parties
pour ses trois premiers zénith et puis
j'ai eu envie de changer je voulais pas
continuer comme ça donc je me suis mis
à écrire d'autres choses avec heu.. de
nouvelles envies toujours dans l'humour
et le mentalisme et quelque chose qui me
ressemble un peu plus pour me stimuler
dans l'écriture je me suis lancé le
défi de faire une vidéo
par jour sur un an
juste pour voir si j'étais capable de
faire ça et je décide donc a ce moment la de
mettre mes vidéos sur youtube puisque
c'est la seule plate-forme
d'hébergement de vidéos que je
connaisse vraiment mais je ne connais
pas réellement ce qu'est Youtube
c'est après, au mois de janvier que
j'ai découvert tout l'univers youtube
et ensuite c'est vous que j'ai découvert
c'est la première fois que j'explique
mon parcours en entier quelque part
donc c'est une vraie mise à nu je sais que
j'ai transformé ce mot mais c'est une
vraie mise à nu et je vous assure 2017
est pleine de projets et de défis je vous
en parlerai dans une prochaine vidéo
début janvier dans tout mon parcours
j'ai également rencontré des gens d'un
talent incroyable et c'est le cas de Zapata
c'est mon pote peintre mais peintre c'est réducteur c'est un artiste complet et
c'est un cadeau incroyable qu'il m'a fait
en participant à cette vidéo
faites moi le cadeaux d'aller visiter sa
chaîne dans quelques jours je sais pas
exactement quand je vais vous faire une
vidéo pour vous annoncer exactement
ce qu'on va faire en 2017 si je me donne des nouveaux défis ou pas
si je continue à faire des vidéos ou
pas n'oubliez pas de cliquer sur la
cloche qu'il y a en bas pour être sûr d'être
notifiés dans cette vidéo la sortira
maintenant les amis c'est moi qui vais
vous mettre un pouce en l'air c'est moi
qui vous envoie comme commentaire merci
beaucoup d'avoir été là toute cette
année
en faisant une vidéo par jour je
pensais que ça m'amènerait au plus
profond de moi et que j'allais me
rencontrer et à la place c'est plus de 238000
amis que j'ai rencontré merci
j'ai la chance d'avoir une communauté
présente
bienveillante intelligente, j'ai eu 366
rendez-vous avec vous cette année
et je vais vous dire un secret
c'est que le début
le mental vlog c'était une vidéo par
jour pendant une année du 1er janvier
au 31 décembre
mais rendez-vous
bientôt !
Ciao!